I'm very glad that together with the
colleagues we could exchange our
experience and discuss the topic of
fostering and developing talents today
we also adopted the conclusions on
promoting new approaches in a youth work
to uncover and develop the potential of
young people for this it is necessary to
take into account the lifestyle of young
people their interest and motivation to
data Council adopted the conclusions on
the prevention of radicalization reading
to violent extremism we reiterate the
objectives of Paris declaration on the
support of citizenship common values of
freedom tolerance and non-discrimination
through education in 2015 ministers
adopted a council resolution on the new
EU skills agenda I want all young people
to have an entrepreneurial experience
before leaving compulsory education next
year I will also present an initiative
on graduate tracking it will help us
better understand how higher education
graduates progress on the job market and
it will allow students to make informed
choices on what to study ministers also
adopted today a concert recommendation
on ask is guaranteed to help low skills
slow skilled adults in Europe increase
their basic skills member states are
responsible for making this up scaling
of a reality but European funds are
there to help